why I guess is the big question why did
it take 17 years for a book that would
seem to be a natural drama spectacle
young adult interest well first of all
young adult interest that's a new phrase
that wasn't as big a phrase 17 years ago
so that's a bee this is a movie that
doesn't fit in a box it doesn't have
just one quadrant it's it's not just for
one set of people and it has really very
powerful themes and ideas and emotions
as well as being a fun summer
blockbuster and try to explain that to
studio heads so as I did that a lot and
we found ourselves across town trying to
tell people how we could do this and
nobody quite grasping it so we think
that's the reason but you know Philip
and I say that you know had it happened
back then we wouldn't have had 0 daya
because she wouldn't have been born yet
I think one of the key reasons for it
finally getting up was that Jeff became
viable again after he won the Academy
Award he became a real asset at the box
office so and then he brought with him
he attracted Merrill so suddenly you had
two heavyweight acting champions world
heavyweight champions and that allowed
the project to go ahead I think it was
the traditional you know finally what
pushed it over the edge was that
traditional piece of casting plus I mean
let's face it Harvey Weinstein have his
kids read the book but Harvey is a guy
who bets on some strange horses you know
and he succeeds when did your because he
grabs the middle ground the ground that
nobody else wants to take Harvey gave me
the book i read it i thought wow you
know this is sort of a combination of
the movies that I've loved making both
the studio films like clear and present
danger through to rabbit proof fence
even stole a shot from rabbit proof
fence the one from above where he's
going through the desert it was a book
of ideas it hit me that sat in a place
that I was really worried about which i
think is the also the reason why this
dystopian fiction and films have been a
success and that is you know that I
embrace technology or it embraces me but
and it's a gift but it's the gift that I
think stealing from us and you know when
I when I read the book I thought wow it
really captures that that feeling that
something's been stolen that the one
word text is not the same as the three
settings phone call or the person to
person call exactly what's a phone call
I saw that Phillip Noyce was directing
it I saw that Jeff Bridges was starring
and producing in it I don't think Mara
was attached yet but I saw that it was
based on the book by Louis I read the
script and immediately I just I thought
this is the best thing i've ever read
this is a character so complex for
someone ate my age has never has never
even been brought to me because Fiona
goes through such a journey she she
starts off being a completely different
different person she kind of evolves
into a human as the story goes along and
I've never been presented with a
character like that so I was I was just
you know it was a dream every every
aspect of this project is a dream if I'm
not mistaken the characters and the book
or 12 years old right why the decision
to advance them to teenage them that was
probably the hardest one and the hardest
one for us as producers to do because
certainly the the biggest shift that
there is from the book but going to
lois's words of staying with the spirit
of the story we really felt there was so
much more we could explore with them
being 16 and you see funny Brenton was
the one who said to us well ceremony of
the 12s it's almost like 12th grade its
high school and we really felt that in a
community where injections take
everything away where you can't feel
being able to see that in a little bit
of an older age group was going to be
give us more opportunity filmic Lee to
explore and we felt like also would open
this project in this book up to a much
wider audience which is something that
we wanted to do odeya where their
challenges for you acting from the
beginning to the end send me robotic lee
almost and then fully alive i don't
think it was ever robotic or bear to
watch yeah yeah i think because we're
reading and i was thinking how are we
going two beers are we gonna like move
differently are we going to eat
differently is this going to be really
static like what how are these people
going to act in the beginning and i
think we just we held it back in the
beginning because we're still we still
are human beings and we don't have
emotion but i feel like with every
character can't help it but there is
something there is something that's a
little bit there you know a sure does
tell jokes Fiona does seem caring
there's little things in there and with
Phil I think I wasn't sure how my
character would develop until I saw the
final the final cup because some takes
he would say okay now take it all inside
take it all inside some takes he would
say look at Jonah's with so much love
look at him with anger and then we would
do a wide range of takes for for every
single Cena then I think the way he
caught it together in the beginning it
is all the takes over
were more composed and and more kind of
naive and happy then towards the end you
used the stronger takes though we did
that day